today on the mat well show a bunch of
liberal academics have signed a letter
speaking out against canceled culture
and most everybody else on the left of
course is furious about the letter but I
think letters and respectful dialogue
just are not gonna cut it at this point
they're not gonna they're not gonna stop
the madness or defeat the the cancel
culture mob there is a solution to
cancel culture but it's not for the
faint of heart it's not for those who
might be a little squeamish we'll talk
about what that solution is today also
five headlines and our daily
cancellation all of that coming up but
before we get to any of that our show
today is brought to you by our new
sponsors over at blink sale which is the
revolutionary invoicing software that's
changing the landscape for small
businesses businesses and independent
contractors everywhere you know of
course the quintessential American dream
is owning a small business but once you
do you discover that there are all kinds
of little hassles and not so little
hassles that you have to deal with
invoices are one of those you know if
you have you ever had to hassle a client
that owes you money or you've gotten
lost trying to keep track of your
invoices and payments that's why over at
blink sale they have built an invoicing
software that helps you stay on top of
your money keep track of everything in
one place so you could stop sending
those nagging emails and you could just
easily get paid for your work with blink
sale you could send beautiful custom
branded invoices and estimates and
seconds you can stay on top of your
hands outstanding invoices you can let
your customers and clients easily pay
for your invoices and much more as an
added bonus blink sales giving like $10
to five hundred daily wire fans here's
how to get it go to blank sale comm
start your 14 day free trial create your
first invoice of $10 and activate an
online payment option you send the
invoice to daily wire at the blink sale
comm and you get paid your $10 as simple
as that it's free money so stop wasting
time invoicing and try blink sale for
free at blink sale comm slash Walsh
that's BL i NK s al e comm slash Walsh
okay so a number of well-known mostly
left-leaning people authors academics
professors media people etcetera have
signed a letter
published in Harper's Magazine about
canceled culture and they're warning
about the dangers of canceled culture JK
Rowling signed it David Brooks steven
pinker a bunch of about 150 people
signed it now this letter has provoked a
strong reaction on the left from other
leftist further left who are furious
about it and minar Taccone the
independent for example the typical of
the reaction it says the letter is
bizarre and that it shows the the
privileged don't like being challenged
Media Matters
especially hates the letter because for
media matters you know this is what they
do
so you attack canceled culture you're
attacking them this is their whole thing
all they do is try to cancel people on
the right that's the that's their entire
mission in life is to cancel people one
staffer at Media Matters has been having
a temper tantrum spanning two days over
this this letter and said at one point
that the signers of the letters are
totalitarians and quote bad people okay
so let's take a gander at this bad evil
totalitarian bizarre letter that was in
Harper's this letter that many on the
left are not just expressly disagreeing
with but actually are enraged by let's
let's take a letter I'll read a little
bit of this letter that says our
cultural institutions are facing a
moment of trial powerful protests for
racial and social justice are leading to
overdue demands for police reform along
with wider calls for greater equality
and inclusion across our society not
least in higher education journalism
philanthropy and the arts but this
needed reckoning has also intensified a
new set of moral attitudes and political
commitments that tend to weaken our
norms of open debate and toleration of
differences in favor of ideological
conformity as we applaud the first
development we also raise our voices
against the second the forces of
illiberal ISM are gaining strength
throughout with throughout the world and
have a powerful ally at Donald Trump who
represents a real threat to democracy
but resistance must not be
to harden into its own brand of dogma or
coercion which right-wing demagogues are
already exploiting this democratic
conclusion we want can be achieved only
if we speak out against the intolerant
climate that has said it in all sides
the free exchange of information and
ideas the lifeblood of a liberal society
is daily becoming more constricted while
we have come to expect this on the
radical right since aureus ness is also
spreading more widely in our culture an
intolerance of opposing views a vogue
for public shaming and ostracism and the
tendency to dissolve complex policy
issues into a blinding moral certainty
we uphold the value of robust and even
cuss to counter speech from all quarters
but it is now all too common for bla bla
bla bla this just goes on or not or not
I think you get the point
so that what you just heard there is
according to Media Matters totalitarian
that represents the Talat arianism they
don't just disagree with it
that's fascist dictator 'real evil
wickedness you see right there Jessica
Valenti said that the letter represents
powerful people playing victim me1 and
this is that's also a common theme on
the left in reaction to this letter is
that these are people are playing victim
who don't want to be held accountable
meanwhile all they did was in very weak
terms really and in a in a you know in a
pretty circumspect way all they said was
hey let's have a debate and let's not
try to get folks fired immediately just
because we disagree with what they say
that's all the letter says and it even
throws in a bunch of stuff about how
Trump is evil and talks about the right
and everything of it make making all
these concessions to the to that to the
canceled culture mob say well you're
right about this and this and this and
this and this and then finally after a
lengthy preamble because this is how it
always goes right when people are
dealing with the canceled culture mob if
they're going to say anything in
defiance of it or critical of it
there's
always a lengthy preamble about all the
things it's right about and then finally
we get to the part where it says or it
sort of gets to the disagreement but
even that you know the left says is
bizarre it's playing victim it's bad
it's a tallit Aryan so I think there are
two things we can take from this and
from the reaction to it first if you
needed proof that canceled culture is
real here it is that many on the Left
are openly hostile to the idea of debate
and dialogue it's not just it used to be
right what we what we used to say is
that the left pretends to be in favor of
debate and dialogue but actually it's
not it's there's a hypocrisy a double
standard well there's actually no
hypocrisy now or very little there's not
much of a double standard because now
what we're hearing is they just they
just don't support this at all
they don't even pretend to support it
they're not interested in having a
debate wrong think wrong opinions wrong
viewpoints should not be tolerated
period it's as simple as that we're not
going to debate with you we have no
interest in that you're wrong you should
be shut down you should be punished I
mean nothing that can happen to you
could be could be overboard what would
you have everything taken from you
everything destroyed you deserve it
that's what the left is saying the
second thing you see I think more even
more important is you see how utterly
pathetically ineffectual letters and
strategies like this are trying to
engage in a thoughtful dialogue about
thoughtful dialogue with people who are
not interested in thoughtful dialogue is
pointless let's have a debate about
whether we should have debates well
you're having the debate or you're
trying to have it because there are
people who don't want to have debates so
if the people you're trying to debate
don't care about having debates then
they aren't going to debate debates with
you you see the problem we are way way
way past the point where anything can be
gained by calmly and politely explaining
why you don't think people should be
canceled or why you should be canceled
they don't care the mob doesn't care
it's a mob behaving like mobs always do
so this is not the solution to cancel
culture this will do nothing letters
like this will have no effect I'll tell
you what the solution what the actual
solution is in just a second but first a
word from our very good friends over at
Rock Auto you know it's um IIIi think
never having to go to an auto parts
store again would be something that most
of us wouldn't miss because why go
through the hassle and everything
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and dealing with
all of that especially when you go and
more often than not they're gonna
they're just gonna go online and order
it anyway we don't have the part in we
got it order it right how many times
have we all heard that from an auto
parts store you have access to
rockauto.com
at your desk in your pocket you carried
around all the time just go to
rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing their
prices based on what they think they can
get out of you they're not going to do
that rockauto.com is an honest business
a family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
reliably low so you get the great
selection that's the word I'm looking
for and also low prices go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you okay
so what is the solution to cancel
culture this is it I'll tell you what it
is I've told you this before I'll say it
again I'll keep saying the only way to
stop cancel culture the only way to stop
the mob is to never apologize to it to
give it nothing to make no
sessions to offend it on purpose just
out of principle and to laugh in its
face that's it that's the solution there
is no other solution if you don't like
that solution okay well but that's the
only one there isn't another one this is
a battle of wills this is one side
trying to impose itself exercise its
power punish dissent get vengeance
revenge you don't deal with people like
that who have those kinds of intentions
by being polite and saying now guys I
understand where you're coming from and
your concerns are so legitimate and
important and before I say anything else
here are a number of issues I agree with
you on in fact I agree with you on
almost everything when it comes to it
because you're very brilliant and
insightful people and as I wouldn't say
anything about you that would be
personally critical and I care so much
about your feelings your feelings are so
important to me such a deepen in
visceral level but now that I've said
all that can I please allow me to
present an argument explaining why for
my perspective there's a bla bla bla bla
bla know that what do you think that's
going to achieve they aren't interested
in that they don't care they want you to
get to the cut to the chase are you
gonna bow bend the knee surrender give
up or not that's all they care about
your choices are either to do what they
want or not and if not then defiance
resilience and firmness are the only
other options you beat an opponent by
taking away whatever power it has over
you you have to neutralize it there
can't be any here's the other thing
about well why can't we have compromise
and discussion well you're not gonna
compromise with someone they're not
gonna compromise with you if they think
they can get everything they want anyway
compromise only happens when both
parties involved in the comp
I realize that they're not gonna get
everything they want and so they have no
choice but that compromise a compromise
that someone does or agrees to when they
don't have to because they could get
everything you want that's not a
compromise that's charity and if you're
looking for charity from the cancel call
for mob then you're really stupid but a
compromise is something that if they if
they're not if an opponent
it doesn't matter whether we're on a
battlefield or negotiating a salary in
your boss's office whatever it is
there's only gonna be a compromise or
negotiation if the person you're dealing
with realizes they're not gonna get
everything they want if you've made it
clear they if you've made it clear to
them that they can get everything they
want why they're not gonna compromise
with why should they as long as the
opponent has power over you it will
achieve victory after victory it will
never compromise because there's no
reason to why compromise when you can
have an unconditional surrender instead
why take only some when you can have
everything so that's why you have to
take away the power how do you take away
power from the canceled culture mom well
by neutralizing its weapon and its
weapon is primarily emotional the mob
says it feels deeply hurt deeply
offended terribly injured by whatever
opinion or idea you expressed and they
they need all kinds of things to be done
to make them feel better
it's nonsense of course there's nothing
but a ploy it's manipulation it's
blackmail but most of the time the
targets of this manipulation will say oh
I'm so sorry I made you feel that way
please don't be mad at me please don't
be mad at me I'm so so sorry no the way
you neutralized that weapon
take away that power is by saying I
don't care how you feel I don't
apologize to you your feelings are
irrelevant to me I don't care if you
have pee
TSD for the rest of your life because of
what I said I'll sleep like a baby
tonight anyway in fact I'll laugh at you
I'm happy about it I'm happy I upset you
I don't care about your feelings and I'm
not gonna explain myself either don't
like what I said deal with it it's your
problem it's not mine now get the hell
out of my face now of course if only a
few people are dealing with the mob this
way then the mob will be able to
continue on basically unimpeded it will
often probably be able to punish those
few dissenters punish them for their
defiance by taking away their job their
livelihood and whatever else that's the
way it always goes if only a few people
have the guts to stand up to a bully
then you know there especially when
they're so outnumbered then then they're
gonna pay a price for that but there
always have to be some people who will
who will you know lead by example if
enough people deal with the mob like
this then they'll be defeated because
that's the thing they only have the
power we give them when someone is using
emotional blackmail it's it's only it's
it's not like they're using physical
weapons well in fact the mob is using
physical weapons increasingly so and and
the more that they're emboldened the
more they will do so but most of the
time when we're talking about canceled
culture it's a weapon that has to be
given to them it's an emotional weapon
emotional blackmail if you don't care
about
feelings if enough people don't care
about their feelings then they got
nowhere else to go all they can do is
put their tail between their legs and go
home and shut up
that's the only solution now I also want
to stipulate one other thing here that a
lot of what I'm saying here in an ideal
situation this is not the position that
I would take okay in an ideal situation
under normal circumstances I actually
would not say that your feelings don't
matter and I'm never gonna apologize in
principle there's apologies can be good
if you do the wrong thing you should
apologize in principle we should care
within reason how people feel you know
now that we shouldn't ever put someone's
feelings as the the number-one priority
above all things but it should be a
concern under normal circumstances in an
ideal situation but these are not normal
circumstances and this is not an ideal
situation and so that's why we have to
adopt this approach it's the same thing
I've been saying with the statues under
normal circumstances in an ideal
situation if you didn't have mobs
running through the streets going crazy
trying to tear down statues and
destroying cities and everything else
and we were just having a conversation
about one particular statue and someone
was making an argument that hey you know
this statue maybe we don't need it for
this and that reason maybe I would
listen to that but that's that's not the
situation we're in right now so even if
there's a statue here or there that a
reasonable person could argue is
shouldn't be shouldn't have never should
have never been put up and and and there
may be there could be maybe there's a
reason to take it down even if on a
normal circumstance a reasonable person
can argue that the position that we that
we have to take right now and that I
take is that we can't remove any statues
because we
can't do it like this under these
circumstances at the behest of a raging
mob and it's the same thing here when
when you've got a mob of people who are
who are using emotional blackmail as a
tool the shutdown free speech the
shutdown open discussion to impose their
will then the only choice is to say no
no to stand firm draw the line and say
no I'm not doing this I'm not going
along with it
I don't care about your feelings it's
the same thing parents have to do right
there's another analogy and a lot of
these people are like children so maybe
that's the best analogy we can use there
there are plenty of times as parents
when we don't allow our kids to do
something that in another circumstance
we may allow them to do I mean there are
plenty of times when my kids want a
snack and no I don't have anything
against giving them snacks normally but
maybe I don't like the way they asked or
they're pestering me too much about or
they're not being respectful and because
of that I'm gonna say no you can't have
a snack normally I would say fine you
want a snack you can have it but not
like that when you come to me like that
and you're stomping your feet and you
have an attitude
the answer's no parents do that all the
time because of your tone because of the
way that you're you're coming at me
right now
the answer's no maybe otherwise it would
have been yes but not now well the
cancel culture is a bunch of children a
bunch of toddlers stomping their feet
well unfortunately we wield a lot more
power than the toddlers in your house
who are asking for a you know crackers
or whatever but our approach has to be
the same thing as parents and say no
when you come at me like that you're
using these tactics the answer is no
you're not getting an apology you're not
getting anything you get nothing from me
at all
period
all right let's move on to our headlines
number one Donald Trump is pushing for
schools to be reopened in the fall the
media Democrats course are saying that
Trump is trying to kill our kids and and
that's what Jennifer Rubin the
Washington Post's major scare quotes
here conservative op-ed writer said on
Twitter that Donald Trump wants to kill
your kids verbatim that's what you said
because he wants to reopen schools yet
the interesting thing is that none of
the people so far as I can tell who now
insist on schools being closed for
coated insisted on the same during flu
season the flu even with a vaccine is
more deadly to kids than kovat but
nobody ever says close the schools
during flu flu season every once in a
while you hear about an individual
school shutting down for a few days
because of a really bad outbreak in that
you know in that locality but you never
have anything like a nationwide shut
down during flu season why on one hand
you have a contagious disease that
rarely causes serious complications or
death in children but sometimes does on
the other hand you have a contagious
disease that even more rarely causes
serious complications or death in
children but an even more rare
circumstances sometimes does why would
we shut down schools for the latter but
not the former it makes no sense unless
of course shutting down schools has
nothing to do with health and is more
about politics and narrative which
obviously is the case here number two a
politician in Oregon received a
disturbing deeply disturbing racist
letter last week and went viral on
Facebook was covered by the news media
really rough stuff that in this letter
racist letter the only problem is that
the politician Jonathan Lopez wrote it
himself shocker of all shockers the
twist ending no one saw coming so after
a few days he admitted yeah he wrote it
himself just for fun let's read the
letter that Lopez his alter-ego sent to
himself the letter says Mr Lopez you're
not welcome here and we'll never be
anything in this community or state
don't waste your time trying to become
anything in this country we will make
sure you never win and your family
suffers along with all the
they're effing Mexicans in the area
sincerely America sincerely America once
again the hoaxers are just having a lot
of trouble coming up with a believable
script for their imaginary racists which
just shows you like we talked about all
the time you know if this is such a
racist country why are why are people
constantly having to invent these these
instances of racism but even more than
that not just that it's being invented
but if it's such a racist country like
you would think that someone like
jonathan lopez would have encountered
racism in the past and so he could write
a believable script of what a racist
would say to him but he's not he's going
based on what he sees in the movies and
TV shows and so that finally kept
speaking of implausible events by the
way while we're on the subject of
dubious hate crimes there was a very
strange hate crime incident reported a
few weeks ago that you may have heard
about a few weeks ago you probably
haven't heard about in the last two
weeks because strangely enough it
disappeared from the headlines but
here's the report that ABC did on the
story back on On June 26th watch this
while waiting for a green light this is
where Althea Bernstein says four white
men yelled a racial slur at her before
attacking her and setting her on fire
with lighter fluid Michael Johnson with
the Boys and Girls Club says he can't
think of a more obvious instance of a
hate crime and so she has burns to her
face bars to her neck Johnson speaking
on behalf of the Bernstein family says
Althea is physically doing well today
her mom and her dad is concerned about
you know her mental well-being and scars
they're suing her Bernstein told Madison
365 Wednesday that the attack happened
early Wednesday morning at around 1:00
she says she was at the intersection
when four white men and floral shirts
yelled the N word sprayed her with
lighter fluid and then threw a lit
lighter at her and here's a young lady
was mine at her
business and somebody decided it tried
to set her on fire and it's it's it's
it's it's unacceptable Madison Police
say they are investigating this as a
hate crime
Johnson says this is an escalation of
racial tensions felt all across the
country that somebody tried to cause
bodily harm to somebody because of the
color of their skin and you know all of
these things that's happened across our
country right here in our backyard it's
just unacceptable and where's the
respect for Humanity okay and here are
the burns that she allegedly suffered
from having her face set on fire you see
it there so she said she was at a red
light 1:00 in the morning a roving band
of racists in Hawaiian shirts ran up
with lighter fluid and a match and a
lighter rather spray der the lighter
Fleury face then threw a lighter into
the car a lighter that stayed lit as it
was thrown somehow so must been one of
those old-fashioned ones that you people
use in the movies and then her face was
set on fire
oddly her hair was not damaged though
her face was on fire her hair didn't
catch somehow and then the racist
disappeared to this point we have seen
no video of this even though it happened
in an intersection in the city there's
no video no surveillance video that
we've seen there are no other witnesses
of this there's a gang of murderous
flame wielding Hawaiians sure did
racists walking through the street
apparently not noticed by anyone else
and even though they're patrolling the
streets lighting women on fire nobody
else reported a violent encounter with
them or any other kind of encounter hmm
and those injuries you know is that what
your face looks like after being set on
fire I don't know my face has never been
so on fire but is that it's it that's a
it's a very bizarre very strange burn
marks considering what she claims
happened and also where is the lighter
that they threw shouldn't she have that
because they threw in [ __ ] I mean she
should have it and and they're their
prints on it but she never mentioned
having the lighter she never showed a
picture of that
and then what about damage to her car
you know if she's on fire in her car
there should at least be some fire
damage around you know around maybe the
doorframe maybe on the on the roof of
the car well we never saw a picture of
that either and and here's another
strange thing there was there was arson
there was there was arson going on that
night confirmed arson leftist rioters
were setting buildings on fire in the
city and that was on the same night this
supposedly happened so she comes home
with mysterious burn marks the same
night that arsonists are running through
the street and she tells a story about
flame throwing racists who nobody else
ever saw and who apparently evaded
detection by every video camera in the
city hmm number three campus reform did
one of those classic dumb people on the
street videos this time asking mostly
college aged kids it looks like
questions about July 4th and why we
celebrated and no surprise a bunch of
people didn't know a damn thing about
July 4th or why we celebrated or or
about American history but the really
disturbing part of the video is this so
we're actually very to interesting
people to talk to we're teachers so I
was a seventh grade civics teacher
government teacher and she is an
elementary school teacher 4th grade 2nd
grade elementary school teacher what
year did we get our independence 17
something I personally know firsthand
that we are not getting taught
specifically in social studies the
history that we need to know I actually
don't teach what's in our curriculum I'm
teaching children social studies that's
not in our curricula I'm teaching them
things about how to be an anti-racist
instead of teaching those same three
famous black people that we continue to
teach I taught them about protesting I
taught them about black lives matter I
taught them about things that are
happening currently so that they could
make those connections and when they see
it on the news they're informed they're
not ignoring the facts of our world
right now there are facts that were
actually a racist country okay so those
are the people that are teaching our
kids
which puts this part of the video into
perspective so with the fourth of July
coming up we're gonna ask a couple
questions my first question for you guys
is what does the fourth of July
commemorate day we declared independence
from Great Britain basically America's
birthday right a independence what year
did we declare our independence I'm
gonna be real cute I don't know 1967
Aussie clothes 1859 1964 I'm gonna give
you a try what do you think what year
did we get our independence 1970
something 74 isn't like that
1979 like the 1800s 1864 yes it's
further back from the eighteen hundred's
Oh
1777 yes that's a shocker is it that's
is impossible to figure out how that
could happen who could connect these
dots I don't know you've got teachers
one of whom teaches civics teaches
government doesn't know the date of our
independence somehow and then another
one who confesses that she doesn't even
follow a curriculum all she does is
teach about why racism is bad and then
you've got a bunch of kids who are
absolute morons and know nothing about
this country or its history how could
that happen I don't know I just I don't
get it but let's continue sending our
kids to public school anyway it sounds
like a great plan number four the ACLU
is calling attention to the case of
Wesley perky who's a 68 year old man
with Alzheimer's and other mental
illnesses who's also on death row and
scheduled to be executed in a week I
think on July 15th he's gonna be
executed the ACLU says this is a
terrible injustice the media agrees
Newsweek has a long article about poor
Wesley poor ol Wesley just a nice old
man gonna be killed by the state poor
guy right but the interesting thing is
that is that Newsweek has this entire
article talking about the poor old man
and how he's gonna be executed and he
doesn't understand why
but throughout the entire article they
never mention what he did to land on
death row in the first place it's not
until you get to the very bottom in a
bracketed editor's note where it happens
to mention what the old man did to land
himself on death row I'll tell you what
he did he bludgeoned an 80 year old
paralytic woman to death with a hammer
and he kidnapped raped murdered and
dismembered a teenage girl so this is a
guy who did the worst thing imaginable
and followed it up with the other worst
thing imaginable
he is Alzheimer's are not a horrific
aliy evil monster unfit for human
society and I think that point is
relevant I think in a civilized society
this should be quite simple you rape and
murder a child you die you bludgeon an
old woman to death you die that's all
there is no extenuating circumstances
that should change the consequence of
that action there are some things a
person can do that forfeit their right
to be a part of human society in any
capacity even in prison and this is one
of those things and in fact he did two
of those kinds of things and you know
the great thing is it's not a high bar
to get over right don't-don't-don't rape
and murder and dismembered on't bludgeon
old women to death if you can't manage
to get over that bar if that's too high
a standard for you as a person then you
just shouldn't be living anymore
and and it is an undue burden on society
to keep you alive and house you and
shelter you and feed you nobody should
have that responsibility for you you
have made it clear you do not want to be
a part of society anymore and you should
be simply given your wish you know I
think that that the ACLU says that's not
justice I think that's like the very
definition of justice if you ask me
number five finally the Green Party of
Delaware tweeted this I don't know what
it is or why it is or
or anything but I know that it is anyway
and here it is it's a picture of a woman
embracing a dolphin and the caption says
their dolphin human baby is the future
of intelligent life on earth and it's
the only way we'll let dolphins in some
form survive this is from the verified
account of the Green Party of Delaware
which granted it's the Green Party and
it's Delaware so there's probably three
members but still it appears that the
Green Party at least in Delaware is now
advocating for a very specific form of
bestiality which is which is maybe
notable I have to say though I object on
moral grounds and also on every other
ground and on for the record I object
not just on the ground but in the sea
too but I also have to admit that a
dolphin human hybrid baby
would certainly give your life porpoise
so
I had to do it I'm sorry no I'm not
sorry I just said I won't apologize I
will not apologize especially for a for
a well-timed bestiality bun I I just
won't that I won't apologize for okay
let's go to our daily cancellation now
for our daily cancellation we're
canceling everyone involved in this
training session for city employees in
Seattle as reported by local journalist
Christopher Ruffo
he had a Twitter thread about only pull
up his his tweets so he says the city of
seattle held a training session for
white employees called interrupting
internalized racial superiority and
whiteness he says so I did a public
records request to find out exactly what
this means let's go through it together
in this red thread first diversity
trainers informed white participants
that objectivity individualism
intellectualization and comfort are all
vestiges of internalized racial
oppression and then you see that handy
chart they're internalized racial
superiority are you know like you
mentioned arrogance is another one
objectivity so if you try to be
objective you you're a white supremacist
then he continues sometimes both sides
of the coin our oppression our white
employees speaking too much that's
probably the internalized racial
superiority of an imposition or
paternalism our white employees speaking
too little that's oppression too because
silence is violence what's next the City
of Seattle diversity trainers encourage
white employees to practice self-talk
that affirms their complicity in racism
and work on undoing your own whiteness
and then in that in that these are all
documents that he has yet so he provides
the documents so they so they give you
the the self-talk that you should be
engaging in this is I guess it's like a
repeating a mantra to yourself racism is
not our fault but we are responsible so
what they're telling you to do I think
if I can decipher and interpret all the
left this mumbo-jumbo is they're telling
you I guess to wake up in the morning
and look in the mirror and just repeat
that to yourself racism is not our fault
that we are responsible racism is not
our fault but we are responsible racism
is not our fault but we are responsible
I don't know if you're supposed to do
this when you when you well that's
actually sorry that's I just did a
symbol of widespread that that you don't
this is just this is that's a proof
right there what I just did is proof of
internalized racial superiority you know
you just you can't escape it what
happens in a Ruffo continues what
happens after the thought exercises it's
time to do the work the trainer's ask
white employees to let go of comfort
guaranteed physical safety control over
the land social status and relationships
with some other white people then the
document says letting go of the things
we have to give up in order to be
accomplices such as at times guaranteed
physical safety
so to prioritize your own safety is also
white supremacy just so you're if you're
keeping track at home and it continues
from there it explains that parently
arabs are white so there's something
called assimilation into whiteness and
if you're if you're an arab then you're
white if you're jewish and white german
italian Armenian all white and then it
continues let's see how do you know when
you've successfully interrupted your
whiteness well when you implicate
yourself in racism when other white
people may be angry and when you have
stopped your white normative behavior so
that's how you know okay there's a lot
you can go to his Twitter thread and
look at all this if you have the stomach
for it now you listen to all that and I
have often not just me but many on the
right have often described this kind of
thing as cultish right but what we have
to understand is that cultish is a very
literal description here I think this is
actually how cults operate the only
thing that that makes the modern left
not a cult is that there isn't one
leader or one established group of
leaders but it used
many of the same tactics as a cult so if
you listen to former cult members or
people who have studied cults they'll
tell you that cults for example often
target young people and college students
if that reminds you of anyone
cults work by isolating recruits from
their family and their friends making
them dividing making them suspicious of
their family cutting them off remember
that BLM on their website says that we
have to dismantle the the nuclear family
okay this is what the left does it tries
to sever people from their families
cults also provide affirmation and
affection but it's tentative you know
you only receive it if you do certain
things if you abide by the rules
cults wield guilt and fear they want
recruits to feel broken and sick in need
of absolution and fulfillment cults do
not tolerate criticism of their core
beliefs and doctrines there's not gonna
be any discussion of it I mean you go
down the list and leftism follow this
follows the script almost exactly and
that's what we're up against we're up
against an ideology that is that has
organized itself literally like a cult
and uses the exact same methods only
it's being done on a massive scale and
rather than having to go to some creepy
cult camp out in the desert the creepy
cult camps are our schools and
universities and we're sending millions
of kids into it and that's what we're up
against and that's why all these people
are cancelled and we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]